-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Billy Porter.
So this is a romantic comedy
that focuses around
a trans character.
Was it rewarding to tell
this kind of story
that we rarely, if ever, see?
-Yeah, we need to put
some joy out into the world.
-I think that's right.
-And, you know, coming --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, and coming from "Pose,"
most of the trans stories and
LGBTQ+ stories that we see,
particularly trans,
are always about the trauma.
-Mm-hmm.
-And I was so drawn to
this piece because
it's about trans joy.
It's about celebration.
It's about the normalizing
and the humanizing
of a group of people that have
been dehumanized.
And so it's in the spirit
of old John Hughes movies,
coming-of-age rom-coms,
and the characters look like
what the world looks like today.
And I just feel so blessed to
be able to sort of
usher this kind of art out
into the world.
It's really lovely.
-That is really special.
It's also, as you mentioned,
you did it.
You went back,
you filmed it in Pittsburgh.
-Yes.
-And you got to pull people
from your past life into
the whole production.
-Yeah, you know,
I was reading the script
and it just happened to be
written in Pittsburgh,
and when I was casting,
I thought,
"Oh, I have so many angels
there, so many friends there,"
so most of the characters that
are ancillary
are either my friends,
like the mother of Khal
and the nurse and the teacher,
we all did Kennywood Park
together back in the '80s.
-Alright, so real quick,
Kennywood Park
is the Pittsburgh
amusement park.
-Yes.
-You worked there?
-I worked there for three
summers, doing the shows.
-What were the shows?
-Oh, my God.
I can't even remember.
They were good, though.
Six different shows.
-So you weren't, like,
selling funnel cake
or tickets to the Tilt-a-Whirl.
-No, no.
I was on the stage, letting
the kids have it, honey.
You know, singing --
♪ Wake me up before you go-go ♪
You know? We were performing.
So I had those people.
One of my mentors that got me
to Carnegie Mellon,
Lenora Nemetz, a Fosse dancer,
she plays the art teacher.
Vanita Harbour
and Renee Goldsberry,
we all went to Carnegie Mellon
together,
so they play the two moms.
Billy Hartung, who I went to
dance class with
on the other side of town.
His mom and dad would put us
in the pickup truck
and drive me all the way to
the other side of town.
Home at 10:00 after dance class.
You know?
It's really a love letter
to Pittsburgh
and the chosen family and
the mentors and the friends
who raised me, because
I wouldn't be here
if it wasn't for that.
And a lot of people still think
that Pittsburgh is like,
this old, depressed steel town.
And child, it's not.
[ Applause ]
She's fabulous
and she's progressive.
-Yeah?
-And she's, you know,
Obama had the first
G20 summit there,
because Pittsburgh was one of
the only cities
that was not affected by
the 2008 recession.
So I wanted to, like,
give Pittsburgh some shine.
-Yeah, well, you know that will
enamor you to my father,
who's a child of Pittsburgh.
-I know!
-His favorite guests are
the ones who talk kindly
about Pittsburgh.
A lot of times, directors,
I feel like
maybe the stereotype is
they look a little
schlubby on set, you know?
They obviously are very busy.
They don't have time to worry
about their outfits.
I'm happy to report that was
not the case with
director Billy Porter.
Look at you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You just don't take a day off,
do you?
[ Applause ]
-You know,
that's a caftan moment.
I found the caftan situation
during COVID.
It's a really, really easy
silhouette.
-Yeah.
-You get a good pattern,
and you just put it on,
and I'm like Bea Arthur.
-Yeah.
-You know?
-We have to find things from
the pandemic
that were teachable moments.
-Yes, and so I had
those moments,
and, you know, like I said
the last time,
I want to be
the Head Bitch in Charge,
so you gotta dress for
the job you want.
The one you have, honey,
every day.
[ Applause ]
-Wait, my last question.
And by the way, I do like
checking in on
the progress of you achieving
Head Bitch in Charge.
-Yes, yes.
-I do feel like every time,
we're a little closer.
-I'm closer and closer.
-One might say you've
achieved it,
but we don't want to put
your fire out.
-No, not yet.
I have some more [bleep] to do.
I only said that because I think
I just heard you
drop the [bleep] bomb earlier.
We're allowed to do that now?
-Yeah!
-Alright.
-We're on very late at night.
-Get ready, bitches!
I work blue.
[ Laughter ]
Ooh, I made you laugh.
-You did make me laugh.
It's fun to have somebody
say they work blue
when there's so much blue.
There's so much actual blue,
on the eyes and...
Alright, ready?
This director's chair. Explain.
-I don't like director's chairs.
They are awkward.
They are uncomfortable.
-Uh-huh.
-And I don't like
sitting in them.
And so, you know, Ryan Murphy,
my mentor,
comes to work to direct
with his own chair.
They bring a chair in for him,
and I was like,
"I'mma do my Ryan Murphy thing,
get my own chair!"
-Well, you deserve it.
-And so I got my own chair,
and it was comfortable.
-There you go. Caftan, chair,
movie, check, check, check.
Thank you for being here, Billy.
-Thank you.
-Always such a pleasure.
Love having you.
-Thank you, thank you.
-Billy Porter,
"Anything's Possible" is
streaming now on Prime Video.
We'll be right back
with Jane Mayer, everybody.